the majority of the world doesn't have
access to banking systems or banking
accounts right so they cannot create
an account into custodian system that
require a banking account right that's
just by design it's like that so they
need access and so the only way to
provide access to those people is by
providing something that is
decentralized and non-custodial
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with leumitech
sponsored by hippo insurance opposed
labs touring hillel at stanford leap and
in media partnership with ctec welcome
to another episode of 20 minute leaders
i'm honored to be joined by uriel hayon
the ceo of xengo a new generation of
all-in-one crypto wallet focused on
simplicity and safety he's a former
executive at icq and aol founder of
techcrunch france which sold to aol
izai.fr a leading french vc among many
more things he is french and israeli
based in tel aviv
welcome to 20 minute leaders from serona
in tel aviv how are you
i'm fine thanks for having me
an entrepreneur an expert in the
cryptocurrency world building a
cryptocurrency wallet and and
you know
i'm really excited to both understand
about your own journey but also
understand the crypto world a little bit
better uh both
your entrance into this world through
the lenses of an entrepreneur but also
through the lenses of a thinker and when
you're looking at this industry and
what's been happening until now and
where we're headed as a society and sort
of as the as a guild that is that is
thinking through the next generation of
decentralized payments real
tell me a little bit about xengo and
about how xango fits into the world of
crypto today
um so it's a big big question but uh so
let's start with the basics first uh
xango is a crypto wallet what makes it
unique is that extremely simple
extremely safe and extremely usable
three properties that you don't always
find in the space where everything is
complicated
feels unsafe and is a source of anxiety
at every moment from the moment you
start to the moment you use to the
moment you need some help
and so we've made it extremely
uh simple for someone to go from zero to
crypto in matter of seconds zero so we
can explain uh the
yeah yeah zero factor two in a few
seconds and
there's a lot of iep and tech behind it
and we came to the space pretty late
when we arrived to that industry the
industry was really already
you know crowded it looked actually late
actually it happened to be very early
yet and but we arrive with a a different
way to think about how to solve the
problem of how to get people started
into the space
and we look we we kind of thought about
orthogonal solutions that were not yet
used in the market but that could
enhance both the experience and the
safety and the security so we're
focusing exclusively on individual
investors we're not focusing on
institutions so we work for individuals
we serve individual investors we have
customers in 100 plus countries in the
world
we start to have a meaningful user base
now because we've been operating for two
plus years we've raised a sizable round
of funding recently with inside partners
which is one of the best gross equity
firm
in the world and they've backed you know
twitter shopify
like you know really big big franchise
brand and our ambition is to build one
of the the most popular
uh brand in in crypto banking and uh so
we're just starting um and the the app
today is considered as one of the best
in the industry
and some people really really like it
and hopefully you know it's going to
grow as as we do and what you can do
with xango is all the basics of what you
need for investing meaning sending
receiving buying selling swapping and
earning interest and very soon having
even a credit card to pay in the real
world so it's really kind of all-in-one
so as a critical thinker in the in the
crypto world take you know take me up 30
000 feet in the air and and walk me
through the landscape of where we are
today you've entered the crypto world i
guess you know three years ago with your
co-founders and you mentioned pretty
late in the game and into a crowded
space yet you're already a key player
and one of the most notable uh
cryptocurrency wallets and you know what
what is your understanding today of
where we are in crypto and where it's
headed
so first the first thing to understand
or the way we look at it is first it's
very very early still always been like
you know 12 years nearly in in bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies and still
very early that's number one number two
is that we've uh we are in a
transitional period where uh more and
more people need want access to
uh better financial systems not just
crypto but just by better financial
services and it happens that crypto is
going to be the default player to to do
that
and the what we are
we are we have observed is that the
first generation of solutions that were
built for this industry
were built for essentially
some
some sort of experts kind of level of
people right you need to have a certain
knowledge about what you're doing either
in terms of security or in terms of
finance or financial knowledge and just
like of in independence of what you know
how to do by yourself and so this fits
well to a first generation of adapter
but it doesn't work with the next
generation of people that are coming to
the industry in particular if you value
convenience in particular if you value
things that can be done from a mobile
phone in particular if you understand
that this industry is extremely new and
still an extreme source of anxiety for
most people including people that are
familiar with it
so once you know that
you understand that there is still
room for innovation the other thing that
we were looking at is that this industry
was supposed and is still supposed to
put the user in control of what he's
doing
the user is the center and you don't put
the user at the center the user should
be the center of whatever you're doing
in crypto and what we've seen for the
past first 10 years is that essentially
all the crypto trades all the
cryptocurrency were held into custodian
system meaning basically replication of
banking systems that held for you
your your funds and it was working
really really well for the first era
because decentralized solutions were
imperfect they were too slow they were
too complicated they still are and so
that was the right way to move forward
but what we are seeing now is that there
is a demand for people who want to be in
charge want to be in control want to
have the custody and the control of
their funds and for that they need to
have usable solutions so the timing was
perfect because at the same moment new
technologies enabled to remove many of
the friction points especially in terms
of security secure private key
management
key management and onboarding systems
and so we arrived and created a new
package
uh solution that makes it extremely
simple for people to go from from zero
to crypto in in a few seconds by putting
them
in control of their funds without
compromising to the ethos of
decentralization and so we believe that
the next 10 years are going to be about
putting creating solutions that will put
the user in the center leaving him in
control of what he's doing in crypto
away from uh
the custodian and centralized solution
so i think this is the kind of the
transition that we are uh observing and
you'll see see that
with with defy and the volume of daily
trading volumes in defy system you see
that with nfts you see that with just
the mere fact that exchanges are
decreasing you see a decreasing volume
of a um the total amount of assets that
the custody uh um moving to
decentralized custodial systems and also
the fact let's let's say the let's look
at the truth the majority of the world
doesn't have access to banking systems
or banking accounts right so they cannot
create
an account into custodian system that
require a banking account right that's
just by design it's like that so they
need access and so the only way to
provide access to those people is by
providing something that is
decentralized and non-custodial so this
is how we're looking at the opportunity
and we still think it's very early
and so if we're looking at in the next
few years what are the big building
blocks that you're observing in terms of
either the consumer behavior or the way
that the world is reacting to to
cryptocurrencies and i'm understanding
that the decentralization of the
custodial of the con custodial systems
that that's a huge part of it and
actually i had no idea that this was you
know a big piece of it but as you're
describing the ethos of of
cryptocurrency it makes perfect sense
that this is the transition we're in and
i'm understanding obviously that we're
only 12 years into even you know bitcoin
and so we're just in the very early
stages but as you're sitting now as the
ceo of xengo and you're thinking through
okay i i'm building to be a market
leader in the next 10 years
what are things that you have to take
into account with the consumer behavior
and the way that the world is shifting
yeah we've seen an acceleration of the
distrust toward the existing
institutions
and organizations that rule the world
what is that trust
how do you define that yeah
yeah you look at it from you know it's
always a generational
behavior you see that the younger
generation have a profound distrust
towards the political institutions or
the financial institutions and the way
it materializes is by the fact that
there is no more empathy between the
generation and the systems right you can
feel that there is a discontent and that
is expressed sometimes or uneditedly
through erratical behaviors that you see
on certain stocks or certain assets so
on stocks we've had the gamestop
episodes right and wall street bets that
is a materialization of that parameter
you've seen the the outrageous
uh and somehow justified raise of dodge
coin which is a cryptocurrency
backed by nothing
which has a meme of a dog as an as an
image and for me the the rise of of
dodge coin is not just the impact of
elon musk because he's tweeting about it
is because it resonates with so many
people who want to say something we want
to send a message and for me this is
like an anti-system
kind of voice that materializes through
this particular cryptocurrency uh so you
have that fact the second is not to to
forget you have an entire
set of the world population billions and
billions of people
including in the u.s people that are on
the bank or unbanked or not well served
by their bank yeah if we love them bank
and they want to have just a fairer way
to get access to financial opportunities
and so for them this is um there is no
alternative right for for example if you
are in nigeria right now
okay you just don't you cannot rely on
your banking system or even on your
national currency if you live in turkey
right now right your lira is the lira is
completely crashing so for them it's not
like a nice to have to think about
cryptocurrencies and bitcoin it's an
urgency they need a parallel system that
enable them
to send money to their peers to their
family to pay their bills to get paid to
create and capture value and to
basically build their personal wealth
and when you cannot rely on your
government on your banking system on
your national currency well you look
into a new system of trust right and
yeah and blockchain and cryptocurrencies
are perfectly time for this moment in
the history of capitalism and the story
of mankind so i think we are in the crux
of all those kind of generational
uh uh patterns but also macroeconomical
and political factors that makes crypto
a necessity it's inevitable i think now
many people have understood it from
investors to institutions to banks to
governments right everyone is aware that
this is going to be a thing that is
there to last and so the question is
where do you as a company fit into that
picture
we've made our choice we decided to
serve ex exclusively and essentially
retail investors we think this is the
where we will do the best job but you
have many companies that are servicing
different type of population and
audiences or geographies
and i think there will be multiple
large companies in into the space our
ambition is to become one of the largest
to become
the global brand for people who will
choose to be in control of their
cryptocurrency versus going to invest
through a paypal
a robin hood a revolut a coinbase or
whatever because they will earn
the control they will earn more
economically also by being in control
and so we want we want that to be a
reality and and so so we could have
chosen the shortcut to build the
custodian system and make 10x more money
as is the case but we are mission driven
our mission is to really get stay close
from the ethos of crypto and make sure
that the decentralization and the
control by the user for the user is
respected
amazing and so you know
what i'm taking away from this you know
and this is something that i'm going to
be thinking for a while is i'm hearing
that there's two sides to the coin here
one side is this anti-trust idea that
we're having these examples of gamestop
and dodge coin which are which are
messages that are being sent by the
society
mostly by people that that do have
access to the banking system but have a
discontent and distrust with the current
way but we're actually saying is
let's not get confused because the real
the real you know idea here is that this
is a necessity in most of the world
there's billions of people that have no
in that have no connection to banking
infrastructure or banking mechanisms and
also also you know in in the western
countries like the united states and so
yes we do have these stories but really
where we're looking at cryptocurrencies
we're looking at something much greater
and that is actually a necessity to this
world and and what it sounds like your
mission with xengo is directed towards
the values of making that world a place
where where people can participate in
this new currency in an affordable and
easy way right
that's correct and and so just to to add
some more color on that what we believe
is that there will be an explosion of
coins and currencies and financial
protocols and systems and that it is
impossible to think that if this is
going to be the foundational layer of of
multiple societies in the world
that people will uh have to rely on a
solution that are unsafe that are
complicated to use that are not designed
for the mobile phone and that will not
look like some some sort of remote
control because no one will want 30
wallets no one will want 30 ways it's
too complicated people have less and
less time and they want and they value
simplicity so simplicity in this
industry is an underrated
value uh most of this industry is
optimized for complexity
and the more complex the more attractive
but the reality is that it connected
even more people from the the uh the
value and the interest because it's just
friction to get to get started with with
things
so focusing on simplicity
is uh is of extreme importance it's a
priority that means saying no to many
opportunities that means saying no to
comp easy compromises
that that means really focusing on a
very clear audience and ignoring other
potentially interesting economical
opportunities and just sticking to uh to
the direction that you want to to go
after so for now we're we we're still
building very much in this direction and
we think it's going to
um to becoming a dominant theme into um
into into the industry
take me back three years
and you're entering this world and
you're deciding to create a company in
the crypto world
what what what steps do you take as an
entrepreneur to both give yourself the
conviction and the confidence to go into
this emerging market which which is not
trivial for new entrepreneurs and and
what did you learn about yourself
through the process
so uh so i don't have a an amazing story
of how i discovered cryptocurrencies uh
except and they're not proud of it that
i was aware of aware of it very very
early on like really year one of bitcoin
but i dismissed it like many people
um it took me years until i realized it
was not only not a scam but it was a
revolution
and i've seen in my career three
revolutions like with my own eyes the
the birth of the internet like really
from nearly day one i created a company
at that moment
the revolution of social networking
where you know content was being created
by username by companies and the
revolution of mobile and when i
finally got seriously into learning
about crypto
uh i recognized the pattern of a
revolution and it was very clear to me
at some point that this was going to
to become a huge tsunami that would
affect not just the financial system but
all our societies and there was no way
i'm going i was going to miss it so so
first it was kind of pattern recognition
of things that i've seen in the past
but i kind of realized about it
really late
too bad for me because i could have
bought bitcoin a much
much better price
but that's that
second once i've realized that this was
something that was going to really
matter and mattered to me i had to find
the idea
and um for me i'm always trying to kind
of connect with a deep pain a deep
personal
pain like that really means something to
me so that it sticks over time because
you know the difficulty in
entrepreneurship
is not to find a good idea
uh is to find a great idea that you will
stick with over time even in difficult
times
for example right now the the market is
kind of crashing and you have to kind of
be able to to stick to things that you
really believe in so that you can go
through those tough tough periods and so
when i started to discover this industry
i started to use all sorts of products
and i was really appalled by what i was
trying including
by the best products of the market and
so at some point i said well
this is going to be the future but those
products looks like fax machine right
they cannot be the future yeah someone
needs to be in something that is way
better the the difficulty that i had at
that moment is always completely
incapable of of thinking about
technologically how to do that because i
was ignorant about it like i'm an
outsider i didn't know anything about it
and i to get really really curious
about it so i went through a long rabbit
hole of learning about about the process
was it was not fast it took me a lot of
time until i i realized what could be
done and found find the people i could
do it with
but i say that at the same time it took
time but it always also the i would say
the cement that helped solidify this
project very early on
and made us stick to through the
difficult period because the more we
were learning about it and learning the
capabilities the more we got really
convinced that we this was going to be
the future and as an example which was
very early on to to build our wallet on
multi-party computation the domain of
cryptography that has been around for 30
years
but at the time was really really early
especially for wallets in custody well
it happens that three years later
multi-party computation has become a de
facto standard for
for crypto security
and that we were especially pioneers in
that domain
and so so we took a we took a very
important bet but we took i think the
right bet and eventually that that is
paying off and so
making those choices slowly but really
conscientiously understanding really the
meaning of it and connecting that to a
thesis
is takes time but this is what i think
eventually pays off you when you make
those traces in a in a careful manner
and so so we we made we made those
choices in that that kind of incubation
period and once we got certainty that we
could build a
product out of it and
we thought that we had the chance at
building something meaningful for the
industry so so it took about a year to
get to that point and so after we
created the company and we started to
work meaning building a team building a
prototype bringing investors you know
launching the baby and making some
mistakes on the way
[Laughter]
tons of bugs and all things all sorts of
things like that but also learning that
we were building something that was
resonating with a lot of people
and that gave us confidence to go
further and further and further so
that's that was the path
incredible ariel thank you so much for
your time this was so wonderful i have
three last questions about you not about
cryptocurrency not about xengo but about
you
back to your childhood what really
fascinated you as a kid
um
flying like a superhero
really
yeah of course i was dreaming about it
like many many kids and i see my own
kids also dreaming about that now
but but there was that also
i would say
i also always wanted to run fast
really really fast
now i'm just a runner but not a fast
runner run marathons and stuff like that
uh but those are two things that were
really fascinating me that was when i
was a really early kid later on i was
fascinated by all the stuff
including tech but that was the thing
that was capturing me
and what inspires you today in your
daily life
um
i would say
trying to think about something that is
really specific
but
i i am fascinated by the perfection of
art meaning that um but that doesn't i
don't think you can apply it
to entrepreneurship i think you know a
lot of what you do when you create a
company is more art than science
right because it's a lot of like trial
and error until you get to a point of
success there's no straight line doesn't
exist even for the brightest companies
and so
so i've been playing music for nearly 40
years and um
if you ask me if i'm more fascinated by
entrepreneurs or by artists i'm more
fascinated by artists and i i like their
quest for absolute perfection and so you
can you can see it you can find it when
you
see that the end result of it is so
simple and so elegant that you do not
feel the effort so i'm fascinated by
people that can manage to achieve that
level of perfection
and this is something that i'm trying to
seek in everything that we do but that
is impossible because amazing the world
of entrepreneurship is is just an
impossible set of equations to resolve
all the time
but this is really the the thing that is
fascinating today
and three words that you would choose to
describe yourself
impatient
curious
and
fast
something like that
thank you very very much i appreciate it
best of luck with xango i'm excited to
continue following the journey and thank
you for taking the time
thank you thank you so much